welcome back everyone to a brand new
episode of the top 10 rules of success
today we'll learn from the richest man
in modern history elon musk and how to
learn anything you want never get
distracted and solve big problems enjoy
i
think you really want to try to learn at
every opportunity and
you know it's great to
read books and
talk to interesting people and
uh
learn as much as possible
um
and um
you know i suppose it was the
[Music]
out of plato or someone who said
um or maybe attributed to socrates
if i
if i know anything it's that i know
nothing
and
so essentially
just taking that attitude that um really
we wish to be less
bullish over time
um but i think it's actually like if you
accept the premise that you were fooled
then
trial
to some degree then i think that if you
wish to be less bullish then
uh that's like i think that's a good
approach you know and um
and
this this avoids
that maximize your feedback and your
ability to learn
um as soon as you start thinking if you
know too much
people can't teach you things
that's when you start getting
very dumb
[Music]
um
so
i yeah i always try to learn learn new
things and um
and and being able to talk to
interesting people
and
you can often learn more by the
questions that are asked and the answers
that are given rule number two don't get
distracted our primary goal is
is to
create the technology necessary to get
people to mars in the absence of which
not you know
it's somewhat academic um
so we wouldn't want to get too
distracted from our primary mission of
we we've got to make it at least
possible to get to go to mars
and we want to
do so as soon as possible
and make
access to mars as widely available as as
possible as affordable as possible so
that if somebody wants to go they can
um
so
that's that's our primary mission um
i mean there are many good causes in the
world but we got to be careful that we
do not try to
um take on too many uh
i mean there are many noble missions but
we
we have to pick our battles and say okay
let's just make sure we get this done
um
and uh
because nobody else is doing it and i i
mean if
spacex doesn't do it i'm not sure
[Music]
how it will happen i think this this is
uh at least right now spacex is
the only hope so we we're going to get
this done and it's far from done i mean
it's
got a lot long way to go
um yeah
i i i it's not like in terms of
providing internet connectivity to
people that really don't have it or it's
very expensive i think will be
helpful in um
empowering a lot of people who are
disempowered today
so i think that's a good thing too rule
number three be optimistic i mean i'm
generally of the view
philosophically philosophically that
it's better to be
optimistic and wrong occasionally than
pessimistic and right
um
you know
[Music]
you i think you want to look on the
right right side of things and um
and i'm a little worried that
um
uh young people today maybe
sometimes are a little pessimistic about
the future
but
like i i'd like to just assure people
that
as long as we are not complacent
we will solve
the environment we'll solve the climate
crisis
and we will solve these issues um
we obviously need to take them seriously
and work hard to solve them they will be
solved um
and that people should be optimistic
about the future and and work to make
that
optimistic future real you know they say
that the best way to predict the future
is to
create it
um
and so if you take the action it's
necessary for there to be a good future
then we will have a good future
um
and um
so i'd encourage people to be optimistic
take the actions that will create a good
future and we will have one rule number
four create something fun what was going
through your mind how how amazed were
you to see your roadster up there with
star man uh just cruising along with the
blue planet and how long will we be
getting live views do you think from the
car
well i think it looks so ridiculous and
impossible
um
and
you can tell it's real because it looks
so fake honestly
we have way better cgi if it was fake
um
and you know the colors all look like
kind of weird in space there's no
atmospheric occlusion you don't you know
like everything looks too crisp
um
and um
but we know we didn't really test any of
those materials for you know as it's
space hardened or whatever you know
so
it just has the same seats that like
normal car has it's just literally a
normal car in space
which i kind of like the absurdity of
that
um
and if you look closely there's a on the
dashboard there's a tiny roadster with a
tiny space man
[Laughter]
so
hot wheels made a hot wheels roadster
and a friend of mine uh
um
suggested hey why don't you put that hot
wheels roadster with a tiny face man on
the you know in the car too like that'd
be cool
sure
so we did that
um i mean it's kind of silly and fun
but i i think
i think that's
you know silly fun things are important
um
and
normally
for new rockets
you know it launched like a block of
concrete or something like that i mean
that's so boring
and i think that's just the imagery of
it is
something that's going to get
people excited around the world
and it's still tripping me out i mean
i'm tripping bulls here
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five solve big
problems i think ai safety is a really
big deal
and we should have some regulatory
agency that is overseeing
ai safety
[Music]
but there is not yet currently any such
thing and just generally any kind of
regulatory agency done by the government
usually takes years to put in place
so
um
you know
after uh
the population collapse issue i think ai
safety is probably the second biggest
threat to the future of civilization
um
and um
yeah
like i said i'm not quite sure what to
do with it
um
i mean tesla
is arguably the
world's biggest robot maker because like
we have basically
semi-semi-autonomous cars that will
ultimately be fully autonomous um and we
are building a humanoid robot that will
be
basically like um like like the car but
with legs
um
so
um
and i kind of uh
held off on doing that for a while
because
you know i i certainly don't want to
hasten the ai apocalypse but clearly
with a look at boston dynamics and like
those humanoid robots are going to
happen so
um they're really going to happen with
or without tesla so it's like tesla i've
got a little bit more i mean a lot more
ability to ensure
robotics safety and ai
and i'll try my best to do that rule
number six be confident my question is
about failure so i was just wondering
what are you trying at the moment or
what do you think you'll attempt in the
future that you're not expecting to
succeed at
well i
i think i think i would stay on on
electric cars and rockets for a while um
and uh
yeah it was actually never never my
intent to to run
tesla
i i kind of
because running two companies is quite
quite a burden actually
um
[Music]
um
i i you know it's sometimes there are
people who who think oh if you're
ceo of the company then they may sort of
imagine themselves if they were ceo of
the company they would grant themselves
lots of vacation um and do lots of fun
things it's like that doesn't work quite
work work that way
um
what you actually get is a distillation
of the
the worst things going on in the company
um
and uh
anyway so i i that the idea of taking on
something more is uh is very frightening
um
but uh
i mean possibly at some point in the
future certainly not the near term there
are i think there's there's
um an opportunity to create
um an electric
jet essentially um and i do think one
could create an electric jet that
that
is really exciting something that would
be supersonic vertical takeoff and
landing pure electric
um
and just just a vaguely forward um i
think i think that's that's a
distinct i i i'm quite confident it's
doable
um for provided that there's
a uh a rough doubling of the energy
density um in in batteries or capacitors
so
basically around around the 500 watt
house per kilogram level is where it
starts to make sense
and then there's um i do think there's
the possibility of kind of a
fifth mode of transport
uh which i've talked about
kind of
mentioned
gently uh which is uh like i i
i i i call kind of the hyperloop
um
and um
[Music]
you know
i i i'd like to sort of publish
something about that maybe in the next
month or two um once tesla is at steady
state production
um
and and i want to flesh it out a little
bit to so that um and and
pre-address some of the rebuttals that
people will come up with
rather than just sort of put it up there
and then happy have the rebuttal occur
and and have an unaddressed rebuttal
but
i guess the way to think of it is
it's like a cross between uh a concord
and a railgun rule number seven sees new
opportunities supposed to be 20 years
old right now where would you start your
path from
i mean if i was literally just
so if it was just a 20 year old right
now in 2021
i was 21 and 21
[Music]
from where would you start
[Laughter]
well i've been assuming that i'm still a
technologist then
i think there's
um a lot of opportunity
in
synthetic
uh
rna
um
the you know the vaccines that were
developed apart from
the like one of the ones that were done
by bayern tech and
um
moderna
are
really the beginning of what i call
digital medicine or medicine and
software
and i think that's i would say what's
the single biggest opportunity i see
right now it's probably
um
synthetic rna
and
the potential for revolutionizing
medicine
in that way um there's also
artificial intelligence
um there's one of my
favorites that
which is tunnels
we need a lot of tunnels to address the
traffic in in major cities
um
and then there's obviously the continued
electrification of transport uh it was
aircrafts and boats
um in addition to cars
um let's see
there's many other things that will come
up as well
so
[Music]
i look we think we live at a very
exciting time
if you look at the whole history
of the world in here you know humanity
this is a time of
the greatest
technological
growth in history
um
and it seems to be accelerating rule
number eight deploy advanced technology
what is it that that makes starling
different to
what's gone on in decades beforehand
elon but also with your new competition
as well what is it that makes you
different
yes um well when i gave a talk a few
years ago about starlink i was asked
what's my goal for starlink and i said
well
our goal is not to go bankrupt
uh every as you point out um every other
low-earth orbit communications
constellation um everdone has gone
bankrupt uh now some of them have
emerged from bankruptcy um
but
the let's just say the original owners
uh did not benefit from
from those constellations
so
um yeah they've either gone bankrupt
after
most of them weren't bankrupt before
even deploying a constellation fully
and and
even the ones that did deploy their
constellation they they saw it bankrupt
you know um
they did subsequently emerge from
bankruptcy but
you know um and obviously companies like
iridium and opcom are are doing
reasonably well today but
not for the original uh owners
um
so step number one for sonic is don't go
bankrupt that
you is then we
if we succeeded in not going back up
then
that'll be great and we can move on from
there
um
but i do think from a technology
standpoint uh starlink is
quite different from
prior leo constellations and that the
technology that we're deploying is is
very advanced
what happens often with space-based
technology
somewhere ironically is that it tends to
be
um
older technology that exists on the
ground
uh so
companies generally have been very
conservative so they've said well we
want
we want technologies proven to work on
the ground and then we have to test it
very you know for four years to make
sure it's going to work in the vacuum of
space with
you know a higher radiation load and
that kind of thing
and uh and so the technology has
generally been launched into orbit has
been older technology and we took the
officer's approach and said we're going
to make technology that is
uh
in some ways at least more advanced than
what is on the ground and we're just
going to take a chance
are the most sophisticated but the most
advanced uh phase rate
uh
technologies
that uh
best of knowledge that no one has not
even it's not even at that sort of
military level uh it has this level of
sophistication with phase grade
technology rule number nine be an
innovator what did you learn what did
falcon heavy teach you
uh teachers i guess told me like crazy
things can come true
um like because i uh
he'd say like i didn't really think this
would work um
because when i see the rocky liftoff i
see like a thousand things that
that could not work and it's amazing
when they do
and i was really that seeing the two
boosters land
synchronized really just like the
simulation
um
i mean it makes you think like you
really that could be quite a scalable
approach you know you could imagine
large numbers of those just
coming in landing taking off landing
doing many flights per day
so it i think gives me a lot of faith
for
our next architecture
the sort of the interplanetary
spaceship um you have different names
for it but bfr is kind of the code name
and
i it gives me confidence that bfr
um is really quite workable
um
i was actually looking at the side
boosters and like they're pretty big you
know 16 stories tall
60 foot leg span
but you really we need to be way bigger
than that
[Music]
so
so i think uh it's given me a lot of
confidence that we can make the bfr
design work
um
yeah
it's
i i mean i've
tremendous confidence obviously the
spacex team
so
[Music]
i think i think we can
really do this a lot you know and and
keep advancing the keep advancing the
technology
to achieve
full and rapid reusability
uh whichever would have a profound
effect on the future and one interesting
things about say falcon heavy versus
falcon 9
is that falcon navy has the same level
of expandability as falcon 9.
so if you say that the price of falcon 9
is 60 million dollars falcon heavy's 90
even though it's got three times as much
capability
because in both cases the only thing
that's expended is the upper stage
we're going to start recovering the the
fairings the big nose cone we're going
to recover that recover the boosters and
so
there's really the cost difference
really between a falcon 9 and falcon
heavy is minor and rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips is have fun
hi
hi
hi
people are going to get checked out and
the cars are going to drive themselves
into what do you think about the ml
human hybrids that we're kind of you
know embracing right now how long are we
going to have these crossover periods i
know you believe sfst is around the
corner do you think this is really a
problem are we going to teach people to
deal with ml
well
i mean the the transition period
to new technology is always a little
bumpy
and
but i think
we published the
the safety stats like basically miles
driven
on
autopilot and miles driven manually and
this
i mean
it's an order of magnitude different so
like people say oh well you're
playing with the statistics i'm like
listen
we're just saying
miles driven an autopilot mile's not
driving watermelon there's a 10 up back
to 10 difference so
i mean even if we were like we're not
fiddling with statistics that's just
it this is not subtle it's what i'm
saying it's not subtle
the truth is that people are actually
not great at driving these two-ton death
machines you know and people get tired
and they um
get drunk and they get distracted and
they text and they do all sorts of
things they shouldn't do
and then the cars that you know crash
basically um
and um
now that now
when we were embarking on the autonomy
front
uh someone told me i think that's quite
true which is even if you
for argument's sake
uh
reduce
fatalities by 90 percent with autonomy
um
the 10 that do die uh with autonomy are
still going to sue you right
the 90
that are living don't even know that
that's the reason they're alive
um
nonetheless um
i've had many conversations with the
tesla autopilot full-size driving team
who are just an
outstanding group of people
um
and saying like listen guys
it is better to
pursue
like the reality of doing the right
thing matters more than the perception
of doing the right thing
and as long as we are confident that
we're doing the right thing even if we
are criticized and sued and all that
we should not only do the right thing
and not
care about simply the perception of the
right thing you want to make something
beautiful i mean
that you want to
trigger whatever
fundamental aesthetic algorithms are
like like in your brain there's
you have i think some intrinsic
uh
elements that that represent beauty um
and
and that that trigger
the emotion of appreciation of beauty in
in your in your mind
um
and i think that these are
these are actually relatively
consistent among people i mean not
completely um some people like not
everyone likes the same thing but there
are there's a lot of commonality it is
important to com
to combine
aesthetic design with functionality like
the thing that's like if you say like
what was really hard about say the model
s or the model x
was to
combine aesthetics and um utility
so to balance the two um you can make a
car look very good by giving it sort of
um certain proportions like making it
sort of low and slim and and um
but
if you uh if you do that the utility is
significantly affected to make a sports
car look good is relatively easy
but to make a sedan look good or an suv
look good is quite difficult really pay
attention to the little details
the
the nuances of of design and shape and
form function and
um
the you know just the way it looks in
different lights and when something's
off the little thing how do you
experience that
it drives me bananas
yeah
um i mean it's the the problem is like
if you
you can train yourself to to pay
attention to the tiny details i think
almost anyone can
um
although it it this is a very much
double-edged sword because then you see
all the little details
and then little things drive you crazy
so
but like most people don't they don't
see they don't consciously see the small
details but they
they do subconsciously see them like you
you sort of your mind takes in a result
of the overall
you know
an overall impression
and you you know if something
is appealing or not even though you may
not be able to point out exactly why
um and it's it's the summation of these
many small details
so most of us experience it as a oh i
think that's ugly or i think that's
beautiful or like wow that's elegant but
yeah can't break it down
you mentioned something in passing like
you can train yourself in this though
yeah you can train yourself i think
you can make yourself
pay attention to to why
um you're essentially
bring the
subconscious awareness into conscious
awareness
god i wish i could do that how do you do
that
just just pay really close attention
almost like a meditation on the object
and trying to find the details like why
do i not like this is that what yeah
just look look closely and carefully
physics training is a very good training
where
it's a good framework for reasoning
where you're trained to
think about first principles and reason
from there and that means boiling things
down to
the most fundamental truths and then
connecting those truths in a way
to try to understand
how reality is because you know physics
has this problem where they're trying to
figure out things that are totally
counter-intuitive
and so they had to have a framework for
for getting there like quantum mechanics
is incredibly counter-intuitive
but it's true um and so you had so
physics developed a framework for
figuring out uh things that aren't
obvious and that's why i think it's it's
not it's it's a lot of advice but it's
it's it's the right framework you think
about the future you want a future
that's better than the past and
so if we had something like the
hyperloop i think that would be like
cool like you'd look forward to the day
that that was working yeah and and it's
something like that even if it was only
who only
was in one place you know from l.a san
francisco or new york to
dc or something like that then um it
would be cool enough that it would be
like a tourist attraction it would be
like a riot yeah so so even if if um
some of the initial assumptions didn't
work out the economics didn't didn't
work out quite as as one expected it
would be like cool enough like i want to
journey that place just to just to write
on that thing that would be pretty cool
um
and
so that's i think how if you cope with a
new technology it should feel like that
you should really
like if you told it to an objective
person would they look forward to the
day that that thing became available and
like you know be pretty exciting to do
something like that
um or an aircraft like i thought it was
really disappointing when the when the
concorde was taken out of commission and
there was no supersonic uh transport
available yeah
and of course the 787 has had some
issues yeah um
so
um
but it's but the thing is the 787 even
the best case scenario is only a
slightly better version of the triple
seven yeah
and it's like okay
i'm not that exciting well i was just
saying that you know you want to take a
moment to appreciate things in life and
the sensations
um
food's incredible
and like there's just so many good
things that you can experience
some of them cost nothing really
um you know
have a walk in nature or
just a nice meal and it's like wow
that's pretty great you know and
we should take a moment to appreciate
these these uh
little things the big things
um the things that move your heart i
think
that's probably the meaning of life as
close a definition as i can think you
know just in general critical thinking
is is good you know examining whether
you have the correct axioms are the most
applicable axioms uh does the logic
necessarily connect um and then
what are the what are the range of
probable outcomes
um outcomes are usually not
deterministic they're
they're they're a range
and so you want to figure out what those
probabilities are and make sure
ideally that you're the house everyone
needs to go you know try to solve like
some big big world-changing problem i
mean i think that
like if
i i really think like
we should just think like are we doing
something that's useful
um to the world like if you're doing
something useful that's great you're
sort of a usefulness optimization
is is like that's like a really good
thing
um you know if you if you've done
something that's useful to
your fellow human beings that's you've
done a really good thing um and
people should feel proud of doing that
um
you know it doesn't doesn't always have
to be something that's going to change
the world i mean sometimes the world
should just keep going in a particular
direction
help the world um yeah it might be
though it might be going in the right
direction
and i mean in a lot of ways the the
world is and we're we are in
in great shape
in that if you look at say violent
crimes um
you know
um
per capita in the world it's at a like
all-time low
um
uh we're actually quite prosperous
and
you know compared to in his history
um and um
you know i think there's a lot of things
to feel good about in terms of how the
world is today
um access to information is incredible i
mean
anyone with like a
100 device could have has access to
basically all the world's information
which is an incredible thing
um
and um yeah so i honestly i just think
like the best thing for people to try to
do is say like hey what is something
that i can do that would really be
be useful uh to the world and
just do that you know that's great i
mean first of all my goal is not
disruption for the sake of instruction
um okay i i really
think there's okay there's some
important things we have to solve in
order for the future to be good yeah i
would say like my
you know
my sort of algorithm or optimization is
like okay what set of things do we need
to do
uh to ensure that the increase the
probability of the future is going to be
good yeah and so if we if we we have to
solve sustainable energy yeah this is
total logical if we do not solve
sustainable energy then we have
unsustainable energy then it's just a
matter of time before things go before
civilization collapses we must but even
beside even if there was not an
environmental issue uh since the
availability of oil is limited yeah
this is not something we can sustain
long term yeah my original interest in
electric vehicles was actually not
environmental it was out of concern just
you know studying physics and i'm like
wait a second yeah we we immediately
transitioned to uh solar electric yeah
uh or we're gonna have a problem and and
we run out of oil civilization collapses
that's a problem now of course the
environmental concerns uh have
added to the urgency
um
because the the more
co2 co2 we put in the oceans and
atmosphere the more we increase the
probability that uh something will go
wrong
like i said like things are much more
probability as opposed to certainty uh
but i think it's an unwise experiment to
dramatically increase the co2 yeah in
the atmosphere and oceans yeah just
given that we know we need to transition
anyway because we ran out of oil yeah so
why run that experiment it's not it
doesn't make any sense um we know we
have to transition to a sustainable
energy economy
um then let's just get on with it yeah
you know let's just get on with it and
not run the crazy experiment and see if
the what happens if the atmosphere has
2000 ppm
co2 this is crazy i wanted to spur ideas
and thinking about
the
long-term need to
capture carbon
and
you know
i think this is one of those things
that's going to take a while to figure
out what the right solution is
and especially to figure out what what
the best economics are for
uh
for co2
removal
and
and all the
things through all the consequences you
don't want the cure to be worse than the
disease yeah uh so
uh
you know sometimes people say well just
plant a bunch of trees i'm like that's
not so easy you know like like a
trillion trees
sure exactly and then you gotta like
okay well how you get fertilizer are you
going to water them where's the water
going to come from uh what habitat are
you potentially destroying where the
trees used to be it's not it's not just
a no-brainer if you just go plan about
it but it's not to say that's not a good
viable option we should plant some trees
i i'm in favor of planting trees
it's just not a question of like okay
um
you know there are like vast sections of
like like the sahara desert or or
uh the you know the some large barren
areas very dry areas in the u.s um where
you couldn't theory plant a lot of trees
but you're going to need a lot of water
yeah and you're going to like like
you're going to have to cultivate them
it's not like they don't just throw some
cheese on the ground
um
or drop them from orbit yeah and i mean
so just
i think it'll be good to sort of
uh
kind of frame the the frame the debate
and and understand okay what things are
really going to move the needle how much
are they going to move the needle
um
you know
uh
if we're talking about
getting tens or hundreds of billions of
tons of carbon
in what form will that carbon be yeah
will it be stable over time
um and like i said
like what is it going to cost humanity
to do however it's paid for what what is
it going to cost what's the thing that's
uh going to take the
you know be most affordable really just
look for
evidence of exceptional ability
so it's not
at least aspirationally like sometimes
these things get
messed up in
recruiting or the recruiting photo
beings it ends up being wrong like i
sometimes wonder with tesla
if nikola tesla applied to tesla would
we even give him an interview it's not
clear
you know this guy came from like some
weird college and
somewhere in eastern europe i think he's
got some odd mannerisms no we don't know
if we should give an interview like i
worry that that's actually what we do
instead of like
right it should be like man [ __ ] this
this this kid's super smart wait what
does he want we'll pay him anything that
should
that should be the reaction if nikola
tesla applies you know to tesla um
ironically
but so i can tell you the intent is
we're looking for evidence of
exceptional ability uh and it really
doesn't matter if you're wanting to
graduate high school or college or
anything we're just looking for evidence
of exceptional ability uh such that it
would be a good predictor for doing
exceptional things spacex only consider
cost actually it just means that if
there are um you want to look at both
the benefits and the cut the cost
actually so
if uh if in um sequestering carbon
removing it from the
atmosphere oceans
uh it has has some uh
perhaps some environmental
impact uh
which might be small but it's not
negative that certainly needs to be
taken into account um
and uh
uh and then a bystander token if uh
what's done is
in extracting carbon is
a useful product sure that from which
you can generate revenue then that
should count too all right so
and i'm just sort of saying for
argument's sake like let's say uh you
could create um
you know um construction construction
material like you know um
cement cement yeah yeah which we just
i'll talk about that later some kind of
useful rocks that are rocks that are
useful or sand or i don't know yeah um
something that's useful for construction
um
then uh you could say okay well this is
what we could sell it for and uh
you know and then
just fully consider pros and cons and
and and say okay this is what
you know if um
if we need to pay to have it done in the
future which we probably will have to do
then
um
what's the what's the lowest net cost i
don't really
like risk for risk sake or anything it's
and and i do think that um
early things are are very risky
uh with a low chance of success but
if you want to try to come up with an
innovative breakthrough
that's kind of that's going to be how it
is
anything
which is significantly innovative is
going to come with a significant risk of
failure
and
but you know if you've got to take big
chances in order for the potential for a
big
positive outcome
um
and um
you know just if
i mean if the
outcome is exciting enough then then
taking a big risk is worthwhile
it's really
i approach it but but then once
executing down a path i actually do my
absolute best to
reduce uh risk you know because
or to improve another way of saying to
improve the probability of succe
[Music]
as you embark down that path
i mean when
um when i started spacex the i thought
the odds of success were very low
um i thought we'd most likely
fail i think in general if you want to
recruit people uh that are
you know really talented and driven you
have to say you have to state what the
what's the mission what's the problem
we're trying to solve yep and and uh
and and just be clearly willing to you
know pour a lot of blood sweat and tears
into it um and have a convincing
argument for why it matters um
you know there's
gonna say like there's three three major
things for
um
you know in terms of motivation uh it's
like first of all somebody's gotta look
forward to coming to work in the morning
like if they're
like are they enjoying
the the work itself intrinsically um
that's very important
um
and uh
the right work environment can really
make a big difference there i think the
ideally is that they also feel like that
their rewards will receive um fair uh
financial compensation like that they're
that you know the that the financial
rewards are
are are good and fair uh and then third
for the really for the best people in
the world they'll want to know are they
is what they're doing going to matter
yeah like so
uh if they spend 10 years doing this it
will make a difference in the world or
you know will people notice but what
matter the reason i got into space
was to try to increase nasa's budget
well god bless you
um
and but so i'll tell you so the
roundabout way i thought that might be
accomplished was
um i thought well if if nasa's budget
was more was larger than we could do
more in space exploration
and i thought well what
what particularly if we could get the
public excited about sending people to
mars
and i thought well if i could do a small
greenhouse and send that to the surface
of mars with seasons
in
nutrient gel and you hydrate the gel and
landing you have a little miniature
greenhouse
and then you you'd have the public tends
to get excited about precedents and
superlatives so we like the
you know sort of first life on mars the
furthest life's ever traveled and get
people sort of excited about what we
should send people there like
the hell with plants we should send
people you know right right um and um
and then um i thought well that could if
if that could
get the public really excited about
sending fuel to mars then that would
translate into congressional support for
a bigger nasa budget that was the goal
um and then i didn't have enough money
to buy
and i thought that that outcome would
have 100 chance of no
no commercial success
yes so the 100 chance of losing all the
money so
so compared to that spacex which i
thought maybe had a 10 chance of success
that was an improvement if you're trying
to convince the public to do something
you have to say okay how's this going to
read
and what message are we going to try to
convey
what will people respond to what would i
respond to if i was you know sort of an
objective member of the public and um so
that's that that's really you know if
you're trying to change people's minds
or get people fired up about something
then you got to think okay what's that
message what what's going to get them
really excited i was just very curious
about the world and
how do we come to be here what's the
meaning of life and all that and
i always had a really intense desire to
understand things and
learn
um
yeah i mean i had sort of an existential
crisis where i guess when i was
11 or 12 or something trying to figure
out what it's all about you know and uh
ultimately occasionally came to the
conclusion that um
we don't really know the answer but
uh but if we increase the scope and
scale of civilization then we
we have a much better chance of
understanding the meaning of life and
why we're here or even what are the
right questions to ask
so therefore
we should strive to expand the scope and
scale of consciousness
to better understand
the questions to ask about the answer
that is the universe it's hard to say
because things have worked out pretty
well in the end so how how big of a
mistake could it have been as the
question is
really really asking um
you know i did lots of dumb things in my
first company and at paypal
um
and uh
you know i think i think sometimes
yeah i don't know there's so many i like
i'm hard-pressed to say this is this is
the biggest one you know
give us one or two
okay um
the biggest mistake in general that i've
made and trying to correct for that is
uh
to put too much of a waiting on
somebody's talent and not enough on
their personality
and i've made that mistake several times
in fact
then i'd say oh gee i'm not going to
make that mistake again then i would
make it a game
um
and and i think it actually matters
uh whether somebody has a good heart
it really does i think i'm kind of
constitutionally just geared to to just
keep going i don't know um
it's uh
um
yeah i mean it just i i
don't know i mean it certainly there are
times when
things don't go well and then
that's quite dispersing for sure
and so then it's difficult to proceed
with the same level of enthusiasm
but
but i do think like i do think the
things that we're doing are are you know
pretty
important to the future
um
and if we don't succeed then
you know there's
well
there's not it's not clear what other
things would succeed
um and if if we don't succeed then we'll
be certainly pointed to as a reason why
people shouldn't even try for these
things
so
i think it's important that we do
whatever is necessary to keep going the
whole reason i started spacex was
actually to try to increase nasa's
budget
um or at least the way i got interested
in space was uh i tried to figure out
why we had not gone to mars and and i
thought well
maybe it's we need to reignite public
excitement in mars so i initially
started off uh with the idea of doing
this like philanthropic mission to send
a small greenhouse to mars um to get the
public excited about uh sending life to
mars yeah um and if we got the public
excited then they would tell
their representatives in congress uh and
to increase nasa's budget
that was the goal but i was no action it
was meant to be a philanthropic thing
yeah um and then i tried i tried to buy
some icbms in russia to do this and
ultimately came to the conclusion that
and that there's actually plenty of will
to to go beyond earth but there needs to
be a way like essentially nasa needs to
have um you know more affordable rockets
that we need to increase the pace of
innovation uh in space and so if we can
give nasa another horse in the stable um
that that is moving faster
and
cost less and
more innovative then that would be a way
to accelerate progress in space so
i i love nasa and always have and always
will underneath your beautiful beast
yeah it's crazy can you believe this
even is even here
i was here a month ago literally
standing right here well not just over
the fence and you know you had a tube
and a pointy tube
and now you've got this i mean how do
you how do you do that is it just sheer
will
is it everyone that driven about the
goal
i think i've learned a lot of lessons
about how to make things go fast um and
then i've
been
propagating those lessons to the spacex
team and we there's just like an
incredibly talented hard-working team at
spacex um in fact at times i think maybe
there's too many talented people at
spacex we have like
you know
too many talented people that were
cornering the markets
um you know but there's like a very
talented group that works super hard and
uh
the
and and just have
t taking the general approach of if if a
design is taking too long the design is
wrong and therefore the design must be
modified right um to accelerate progress
one of the things i think are like quite
important for the future to be good and
obviously in order for the future to be
good we have to have sustainable energy
so we have to have sustainable
production and consumption of energy
so
that makes means making solar panels low
cost and
making electric cars appealing
and then
we want to become multi-planet species
in a space spring civilization says
rockets um and
uh
and and then there are some things that
i thought well it'll affect the future
but i'm not sure
if it's good or bad uh like ai
that discouraged me that one one of the
most fundamental errors made in advanced
development is to stick to a design even
when it is very complicated um and to
not strive to delete parts and processes
right right it's incredibly important so
this is why
the switch the steel was because the car
the advanced conviver was taking too
long at tesla we're like we're just
going to make electric cars that are
better than gasoline cars faster yeah
lower cost per million they look
beautiful they're faster
and they have also you know cool
advanced technology they're more fun um
you don't have to go to gas stations
which are nasty um
and so
you know but you've got to solve long
distance problems with superchargers
so i think it is actually
you know uh
gonna be way more palatable to people if
if if it's uh
if whatever solution is is removing
carbon does not make their quality of
life worse like we're also gonna enable
people to watch uh like videos like
streaming
through like through the browser you'll
be able to watch uh like you know
netflix or whatever um you know youtube
uh if it's if the car is parked and
connected to wi-fi so if you're like say
at a supercharger station and you want
to watch something uh you can watch it
on the screen in the car um but the
general principle is like how do we you
know what can we do to make the car the
most fun possible um and
um
and like what would a car what other
cars just don't have you know and uh so
it seems like well you know if there's
like a you're just parked somewhere
waiting for somebody
um to finish an appointment or if you're
on a road trip uh be pretty cool if you
just like you know go to the car screen
and and play some like some fun game um
and um and we're just exploring like you
know how do we make it as fun as
possible you can already play all of the
um your old atari games or almost all
atari games on the car um and we hooked
it up so you i can connect uh xbox or
ps4 controller and like actually have
some a pretty good uh control feedback
um and um
then we have like uh genius moves like
the fart app
um
it's my finest work yeah we've actually
spent um a lot of effort on
the spacesuit design
on the
both the functionality and the
aesthetics but i think just just getting
it's actually really hard because if you
just sort of optimize functionality it's
one thing if you optimize for aesthetics
it doesn't work
like you know those things that you see
in movies they don't work
so
the the
so it's like okay how do we make
something that looks cool and works um
and um
with a key uh
goal here of being being that um
you know when
people see that uh space suit they want
them to think yeah i want to wear that
thing one day yeah that looks awesome
um
so that that's uh that's the reason for
it you know what i actually tell a team
is like everyone is a chief engineer
this is extremely important
and that everyone must um understand how
the broadly speaking all the systems in
the vehicle work right um and so that
you
just so you don't have subsystem
optimization because this is naturally
what happens you can see the
organizational errors um
in the like the the product errors
reflect the organizational errors so it
like essentially you'll see that that
there's an interface
at
this point like if you've got whatever
departments you've got that will that
will be where your interfaces are right
and then instead of like getting rid of
something or
uh questioning the constraints
the
one department will
design to the constraints of the other
that the other department has given them
without
calling in to question those constraints
and saying those constraints are wrong
and you should actually take the
approach that the the constraints that
you're given are guaranteed to be some
degree wrong guaranteed to be something
wrong because the the counterpoint would
be that they were perfect right which is
never exactly as you say like what are
the what's the probably this is the
platonic idea or the perfect part zero
okay basically so you could question
your constraints it does not matter if
the person handing you those constraints
while a nobel prize with tesla the the
goal is to
um to try to create electric vehicles
that are more compelling than gasoline
vehicles as a product um
i mean the fundamental issue we have in
um in energy and transport is is
is the tragedy of the commons you know
we've got the co2 capacity of the oceans
and atmosphere that is unpriced or
mostly unpriced
um and so
it's um
it's almost like we're sort of
dumping garbage in the atmosphere
and nobody's paying for garbage
collection um
so
it's um it's the most unfortunate
situation because
the
uh they're quite significant vested
interests in
um in oil gas and coal
um
with enormous amounts of money um
it's quite a difficult battle to fight
and you can't expect them to simply roll
over and commit suicide or something
they're
that they will fight but hardly and then
they have been um
and so unfortunately so it requires
fighting hard
back and
um and and creating
uh products in the absence of there
being attacks on co2 creating products
that don't rely on the relative
economics
of of um using
uh
hydrocarbon fuels versus um
versus electric cars
and so that that was our goal from tesla
from the beginning um
and
i'm really
um
i'm excited to to see that we've um
we've achieved that goal actually with
with the model s
which was
as was mentioned model s was recently
uh awarded um
the top honors by
um
it was awarded some car of the year and
automobile of the year um
and and that was against a very
difficult field of
of gasoline cars
um
and so i'm hopeful this will be seen as
a pivotal moment
in transport where where people
where people you know finally
appreciated that electric car could be
better than a gasoline car what are your
thoughts on the innovations in education
today thank you
i just thoughts on education um
well um
i think there's maybe
um there's definitely some good schools
out there but i think
the
some of the mistakes at least in my
opinion that i see being made in
education is
um that
um
people
the the teachers do not explain
why
kids are being taught a subject
um
you know just sort of get dumped into
math and like well why are you learning
math what's the point of this it seems
like some
you know for some people like maybe it's
i don't know why i'm being asked to do
these strange
problems
but you know the why of things is
extremely important um
because you know our brain has evolved
to
not
to discard information that it thinks is
has no relevance
so then if on the one hand you uh you're
being asked to memorize or learn
uh say formulas
but you do not know why
this is the case then you have this
cognitive dissonance of it seems
irrelevant but i'm being told to
remember it so i'll be punished
so so i better remember it but so the
why of things is very important and
then uh being able to
and then
picking kind of a
a problem
and then
using various educational tools to solve
that problem
like using math or physics or economics
to to solve that problem
is far more engaging
than teaching the tools
you know it's the difference between
if you say well we're going to take
apart this uh this engine
and and see how it works and put it back
together again
and then in order to take the engine
apart we need you know wrenches and
screwdrivers and a winch
and allen keys and and whatnot um
and and said that and then in the course
of solving the problem of taking the
engine apart and putting it back
together you learn about
wrenches and screwdrivers and all the
tools that you need
um and then now you understand the
relevance ah this is why
wrenches are important i
you know whereas if you had a cl
a class on wrenches
you're like
oh my this does not seem that great you
know um so tying it to
solving a problem is i think very
powerful for um establishing relevance
and getting
um
kids excited about what they're working
on
um
and then and uh and having the knowledge
stick if you're gonna try something
innovative then
then you're in unexplored territories so
that odds that something will go wrong
are pretty high uh if you know it's only
if you try to do something that is
already well understood that um there's
a little little chance of failure
but then it will not be
interesting or innovative
so
you know for sure uncharted territory
will result in
failures
necessarily otherwise you're not trying
hard enough spacex you have said
you started with the specific intention
of getting to mars
uh yeah it
well
the origin of spacex uh
was was actually not or
my interest in space my initial thought
in space was that uh
it wasn't possible to create a company
um and i mistakenly thought that
uh
the reason that we're not sending people
to mars was because we'd lost the world
to explore or something like maybe that
and i thought well maybe that needs to
be reignited
and so i
came up with this idea to do a
basically a philanthropic mission to
mars with a hundred percent probability
of losing all the money um
in order to reignite interest in that
goal um
but
after
after a while i realized that that's
that was actually that was
a mistake i mean
particularly the united states is a
nation of explorers
came here from other parts of the world
i think more than any other country is a
distillation of the human spirit of
exploration
there's no lack of will the
but people need to believe that there's
a way
that that in a way that's feasible and
and that it's not gonna bankrupt the
country and their living standard will
be
won't be materially affected you know if
and then i think they're super super
keen on on that that goal i think like
sci-fi uh movies video games
or video you and really i think people
spend a lot of time on on video games
and movies these days uh
you know it can be pretty inspiring and
though provoking about
what's the future that we want
what are some
like impossible sounding technologies
that maybe could work somehow
like there's conceivably a way to do
warp drive but it's like it's
such
esoteric super out in the edge physics
because technically you cannot go faster
than the speed of light
uh but but space can travel faster than
the speed of light
that's what meant by wolf drive
but
the amount of energy you need to warp
space is
unbelievably gigantic so
um
you know you'd have to like be
converting matter to energy at a rate
that is
we just cannot conceive really um
yeah you know it can't be like something
like well if we just compute convert one
jupiter per second to
energy then problem solved uh
like that's a lot and there's not many
jupiters you know
so
uh and there might be a bit of radiation
around that
so
like there are things like like
technically the the universe did expand
faster than the speed of light that's
that's uh that's why we can see
light from
all these super distant stars
um like
yeah so
it's it's kind of pretty wild that space
expanded faster than speed of light
so i'm sure we'll like figure out some
strange breakthroughs
um and you know come to griff's better
with like this uh
this dark matter especially which seems
like
something's fishy going on there
and uh it has bad branding
yeah
yeah
exactly
because the universe is mostly dark
energy and dark matter according to
current current physics but you know
this kind of
plug in the you plug them in the
equations and they sort of work and
they're like
this
this is not a good explanation nobody
can find the dark matter
um but i sort of figure like hey if this
is a video game and somebody had a bug
in there like orbital dynamics uh
physics simulator then i was like oh no
we got to figure out some way for these
minions in here to
believe that they're in reality so
insert dark matter what problems out
there can feasibly be fixed say in our
lifetimes
well i mean i think first of all
um
the world's actually pretty great right
now i mean arguably better than any
point in history
and this this is sometimes uh lost if
you read the
newspapers they're
they're like
a magnification of all
the world's problems it's like
i mean newspapers seem to be attempting
to answer the question what was the
worst thing that happened on earth today
[Applause]
yeah it's
if it bleeds it leads yeah and and it's
like okay i mean and i think there's
there is kind of a evolutionary reason
for that because it makes more sense to
like you want to
prioritize danger over reward or or
because
it's you know if you get eaten by the
lion it's game over but
you know if you if you forget where you
left some snack that's that's okay i
mean you you know so
so there's a
it's it's
not quite the same in terms of the
restaurant balance but
we didn't evolve with newspapers uh and
and and global media so
like our brains sort of having a fear
response to a lot a bunch of dangers
that are extremely unlikely to ever
affect us i'd actually advocate for i
think it's fine if if countries get
together to form teams but i think it's
actually probably better if there are at
least
you know at least two or three
uh country coalitions going going to
mars
um in a friendly way um
and and competing to see who can make
the most progress
um
and if you look at like say the olympics
it would be pretty boring if everyone
just linked arms and crossed the
finishing line at the same time
friendly but it would
you know not be more like the opening
ceremonies yeah yeah exactly yeah um so
yeah i think friendly competition is a
good thing question your constraints it
does not matter if the person handing
you those constraints while a nobel
prize they are even einstein is wrong
some of the time right so uh question
your constraints this is extremely
important
um
and
like and i think another thing that like
you say like what what are the mistakes
that smart engineers make um
like i'd like that one of the
most one of the biggest traps for smart
engineers is optimizing
a thing that shouldn't exist yeah so
they'll just sit there and spin on that
thing that's just like why do we even
have this in the first place
absolutely so the because
um when you go through
college and like studying physics
engineering i study physics uh the
you have to answer the question that the
professor gives you you don't get to say
this is the wrong question right right
um yeah but
in reality uh we have far more degrees
when you're in reality
you have all the degrees of freedom of
reality and so the first thing you
should say is this question is wrong
yeah and that's what you said last year
i mean you kind of said like it took us
a long time to frame the question even
because we didn't necessarily know
the question yeah it's just like the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy douglas
adams best philosopher ever
maybe i think best booker plus if you
ever hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
this book is so deep uh people don't
understand uh but like in the historic
sky to the galaxy the earth is a giant
computer right and and and the earth uh
it comes up with the answer
42 yeah yeah um and then to the question
like so what's the answer to life to use
bursts and everything answers 42 and
like they're like what the hell that
doesn't make any sense right i was like
oh you the really the hard part is the
question question the answer is the easy
part you need a much more powerful
computer to tell you what the question
is right and this is true what's the
point which you can properly frame the
question the answer is comparatively
easy how much time do you have to go
down into the engine room roll up your
sleeves get your hands dirty and fix
stuff as an engineer and how much time
do you spend on the bridge steering and
looking at the at the distant horizon
well
not a lot on that last point
it's
i mean there's a constant flurry of
executional challenges um and so i try
to
triage my time according to what would
be best for the companies
uh
and and still you know have some time to
see my kids because you know because i
don't want to miss them growing enough
so
you know it can vary from big issues to
things that seem small but actually
could have a really big impact um
so i mean it's all the way from
design aesthetics
uh
the details of say the vehicle
functionality
or in the case of the rocket
uh
you know
the avionics propulsion system and
uh
airframe uh
i mean the rocket is kind of a
has more more of a concentrated pucker
factor um
because of you've got it's you've got
these launches
and and
um at least for the car you can do a
recall or like do a software update
that's not going to happen with rocket
so
it's like
passing grade is
100 percent
which is
induces anxiety have us all just
implement rigorously is uh
the sort of five-step process uh first
make your requirements less done your
requirements are definitely done
uh it does not matter who gave them to
you it's particularly dangerous if a
smart person gave you the requirements
because you might not question them
enough try very hard to delete the part
or process um this is actually very
important if you're not uh occasionally
adding things back in you're not just
leading enough right the bias tends to
be very strongly towards
let's add this part or process step in
case we need it but you can you can
basically make in case arguments for so
many things and for a rocket that is
trying to achieve um
try to be the first fully reusable
rocket there's never been a fully useful
rocket people don't understand like this
is like the holy grail of rocketry okay
and
so you really need you have to run at
tight margins because if you don't run
tight margins uh you're going to get
nothing to orbit right
so
uh so you've got to delete the power
process step super important step two
delete the pot or process step if you're
not adding if you're not deleting a
power process step at least temperature
at a time basically if you're not adding
things back in ten percent at a time
you're clearly not deleting enough right
um
and and then uh only the third step is
simplify or optimize the third step yeah
the first step
um
the reason is the third step is because
it's very common
possibly the most common error of a
smart engineer is to optimize the thing
that should not exist
right okay
um and and say well how do we get why
would people do that well everyone's
been trained in in uh high school and
college to that you've got to answer the
questions convergent logic yeah so you
can tell the professor your question is
done you'll get a bad grade you have to
answer the question yeah
so everyone's basically without knowing
it they got like mental straight jacket
on uh that is uh
they'll work on optimizing the thing
that should simply not exist finally you
get to step four which is accelerate
cycle time
you're moving too slowly go faster
but don't go faster until you have
worked on the other three things first
um like if you take if you're doing it
you know
you're great don't dig it faster stop
digging your grave right right
so
but it's you can always make things draw
faster
and then the final step is automate
and now i personally uh made the mistake
of going backwards on all five steps
multiple times well you have to um
imagine an outcome in order to head in
that direction um
and science fiction explores a lot of
different ideas so um it can be
you know helpful as a source of
inspiration um and any you know
like
books
tv shows movies and they're all
uh i think sources of inspiration
most of the movies and tv shows about
space are totally wrong
but
but they still have interesting ideas
like the star trek communicator
was
uh an inspiration for the cell phone
yeah with the flip right right yeah
exactly
um in fact the weird thing is like the
like the phones we have in our pocket
vastly exceed what was on star trek
first of all i think that's very
exciting and inspiring and they need to
be things that are exciting and
inspiring
and
uh make you
look forward to waking up in the morning
like it's like gay future is exciting
this is underappreciated
you know like tunnels
sorry
and um
you know but there's got to be things
that
make you excited about life um but it
can't just be problem solving you know
one one sort of miserable problem after
another it's got to be like i'm fired up
about the future because here's why you
know and space is one of those things
that that does that for people all
around the world
um you know when
um
when
apollo 11 you know when they landed on
the moon i mean it was that was
something for all of humanity it really
was you know people would you know if
there's like one tv for 50 miles around
people would walk you know they'd walk
50 miles just to go find that one tv to
watch it happen
um
so you know sometimes people think what
about what about the poor nations of the
world they're like you know what inspire
inspires them too
and um
you know we need things like that i
think like if if like trying to work on
something
and like my experience is like it's
really hard to and like
if you're trying to figure out what
others love but you don't love it it's
really hard to make that great
so when you work on something
if you fall in love with it that's
that's a good sign um and then don't
worry about if others do if if you do
others will an important thing in in
innovation or trying to cr create new
things is
is to try really hard to do that
which may sound incredibly obvious but
uh
that's what i find is is most often what
people don't do they actually didn't try
super hard to come up with something new
um
and it is helpful to have
cross-pollination of industries um
i mean it's been quite difficult to run
spacex and tesla but
there has been
good ideas
you know since i got both in my mind
space
this this
good idea is going back and forth the
um for example on the car with respect
to the car the model s is the only
all-aluminum
body and chassis car made in north
america and very few cars are are all
aluminum in the air space industry it's
that that's the default um
so it seemed like like
obviously the right move in order to
minimize the the non-battery pack mass
of the car
so in order to offset
you know fairly heavy battery pack we
had to make the rest of the car
light but but still achieve
a five-star safety rating
i don't think it would have been
possible to do that if we had used steel
which is the traditional method
and and what's helped spacex has been
that the car industry is
really good at making complicated
objects at a low cost i mean it's
actually quite incredible that like one
can buy
a decent car for twenty thousand dollars
i mean all the stuff that's in that car
is
i mean it's nutty how much stuff is in a
car
so
at spacex i hired a bunch of people from
the order industry to
run manufacturing which has worked out
reasonably well whatever requirement or
constraint you have it must come with a
name not a department because you can't
ask the department you have to ask a
person yeah and that person who's
putting forward the requirement or
constraint must agree that they must
take responsibility for that requirement
otherwise you can have a requirement
that basically an intern two years ago
randomly came up with off the cuff uh
and they're not even at the company
anymore right uh and and and but it came
from the let's say
aeroloads department they're like uh
actually
there's no one in the airplane's
department actually it currently agrees
with that
this is not this is by the way it
happened several times so again it could
be literally we want to pick on the
arrow because it's like yeah it's every
department you know there's a lot of uh
technical problems to solve um
so i guess we sort of you know started
studying kind of
engineering and physics and biosciences
and that kind of thing would be the
um way to go
um
yeah
um a lot of going to be a lot of
problems to solve to to make a city work
on mars
um
you know we were thinking of just as a
well sort of a semi joke putting a
uh job description on our website for uh
urban planner and brackets mars
but um
you know this there's going to be a
tremendous amount of problems solved
there'll be
there's a lot of building building and
problem solving so those are like the
right you know skills to work on if if
someone's interested in
going beyond earth or you know space in
general what's the actual biggest
failure that you that you've gone
through to get to where you are i mean
we blow up three rockets in the
beginning
[Music]
actually i only had enough money well
originally i only i
basically took all the money i made from
paypal put into
spacex to creating spacex tesla and
solarcity and uh
i
initially figured i'd i just i'd keep
half of it and then i spent the other
half on these crazy adventures that
would probably fail
and then unfortunately they needed all
the money so
so i had to give them all the money and
then i didn't have a house or i had to
borrow money for rent that was was
pretty difficult that was back in 2008
and then we managed to scrape enough
spare parts together to do a fourth
launch at spacex um and that worked and
if it had not worked spacex would have
died and
probably would have lacked the
credibility to raise the remaining money
for tesla
and we wouldn't be here today or maybe
like
not this ending another mistake that
tends to happen in production is too
much in-process testing
so
in the when you're first setting up a
production line
you don't know where this like where
things are are breaking you don't know
where things are breaking so you'll test
uh
like work in process at various steps
um
and because you want to isolate where's
where we where's the mistake occurring
um so a very common mistake uh issue
with production
alliance is to have
um
is to not remove the end process testing
uh after you've
diagnosed where the problems are so
basically if you have like um a very
high acceptance if like if things are
getting to end of line testing and you
know passing uh then you don't need to
do in-process testing
so uh
but what has to happen is they'll be in
it like an initial like development
engineering team that will be like
basically debugging the production line
but then they will forget to take out
the in-process testing steps
uh so then
what happens is the in-process test
tester
will often choke the cycle time
choke the line corruption claim uh it'll
be like the limiter uh it will also have
some number of false positives with
false negatives right uh between the
false positive like then you're like
rejecting good parts right um
so um
really in volume production if you have
uh if things are working well
uh you're really just taking a risk will
this part be re will this
subsystem be rejected at
uh
during in production process or at the
end um and so you just really want to
move things pretty much almost always to
just test at the end line that's it
um
maybe there's like one or two in process
steps
that are hard to test at the end of line
but that but basically remove almost
everything if a startup company did not
create an electric vehicle and show that
it's possible to have an electric car
that looks good goes fast has long range
and that if you created such a thing
that people would buy it then
it would be a very long time before the
large incumbents did so um and so that
was the i felt was important that we
create tesla for that reason i think i
think being in silicon valley is pretty
important because
what's really critical with electric
cars is
uh
electrical engineering software and
electronics
and
silicon valley has the best
concentration of talent in those areas
in the world
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there